hi everyone welcome back to plays of the
week brought to you by ochodo TV
the content shown in this video has been
submitted by various players to ochodo
TV Clips are compiled weekly for a
series of videos highlighting specific
players of their gameplay for the Tekken
Community by no means was it reused or
stolen without permission to the
rightful owner
thanks
[Music]
blue
great
[Music]
time
fight
no
thank you perfect
[Music]
that's okay
come on
[Music]
custom
ers
[Music]
two
six
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
so much perfect
four
fight
s
perfect
[Music]
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
want to be featured in ochodo TV send in
your Clips by following these steps
before you submit your Clips make sure
the quality of the video is clear put
your IGN as a file name for your video
limit submissions to three to five Clips
a week per category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your Clips on avoid
full-length matches or just cut the clip
you want on the desired play Until the
End of the round next send your Clips
via Dropbox in the correct category
find it on the description of every
ochodo TV series
once you upload your video file if it
prompts you to give your name just put
in your igf
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
[Music]
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process
[Music]
thank you